you don't want allies you want servitude
you want man to be in position with you
but you want them scared and you want
them as servants that's what you want
yeah oh I got your gift I got you these
lessons
cut you these blessings because you can
you can go like this
I'm not gonna lie that's fire that is
fine
okay you know what I thought you don't
see [ __ ] hold up hold up
I can only see this perspective so I'm
like this [ __ ] got me black glasses no
but it's really just to do this it's
really it's just stupid but it's really
just it's really just a new oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know I'm gonna do what
are you gonna do
it's a good dude so you see how this
[ __ ] works right you have to press on
the middle and it's like it's normal
charger
because sometimes you know what I mean
because sometimes you mean you you you
making out with the broad things are
going well and then you decide to turn
off the lights and go to the bathroom
and then you come back in she's like oh
get in bed baby and then all of a sudden
it gets dark and the [ __ ] can't see
nothing
I'm [ __ ] you tonight
for five years on from what became known
as the metoo movement there's a growing
back class some influential people are
just become divisive pretty much sex is
against each other was an assumption of
male guilt maybe many young men feeling
marginalized the reason you'd be two
people the Forefront of that backlash
albeit with very different styles of
rationales his psychologist Dr Jordan
Peterson people have been after me for a
long time by because I've been speaking
to disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
uh Jordan Peterson for example the whole
interview has been viewed five and a
half million times on our YouTube
channels rightly or wrongly there's
clearly a huge Groundswell of of
interest at the very least in their
views if not support so what's me too an
overdue Reckoning or has it become a
damaging battle in a raging culture War
Isabel still with me political
journalist Ava Santino conservative
compensated a young man who agrees with
Peterson and Andrew take Connor Thomason
Connor what happened was he went you
agree with Jordan Peterson he went
oh well you just slipped that [ __ ] in
there
you cheeky little bastard I believe that
women deserve equal rights absolutely
but I prefer to change them to the South
what huh got me nodding to the wrong
thing with the camera on my face and if
any man now behaves in a way that looks
like it's toxic masculinity bang they're
expunged is in that process masculinity
itself getting expunged and demonized I
would say so I mean I'm sure that that
you'll have this experience with your
own relationships peers and that women
if you say something controversial if
you say something controversial that's
what I was about to say this guy's name
is Connor Tomlinson he looks and sound
like Connor Tomlinson uh my youngest son
Hephaestus makes an effort to uh enjoy
the Delicacies of the normal life and
there's something to be said about the
fact that you and I as boys and grown
men in this infant Society I've had to
enjoy the peasantry
I'm not gonna lie even just talking like
that I feel like my bank account gets
more money yeah that's why I talk like
that yeah
yeah I know I know it is it's a no he
speaks like he owns the ends you sound
like you're trying to escape the ends
damn well you know what you have to do
what you got to do mate there's a
serious point there a lot of young men
feel they're getting disenfranchised by
Society they're all being over demonized
that any attempt to be the traditional
male figure is now being rubbished and
and called toxic well I mean
if you really felt that and you really
went out there and you were an alpha
male then you wouldn't be bothered about
a bunch of women telling you that you
were there
if you get banned from I mean he's
hardly been canceled he was on your
program which is on National Television
but is there any platform actually he's
had for a long time because all the
social media companies banned him
literally banned him he had his email
gone his Google gone his Facebook gone
it all went down like Domino's well he's
still on there very very prolific on
there I can't move for Clips yeah but
they're not generated by him now but
that's been for quite something but
should he be punished that way but what
it what is what is punished what is
punished when you can't talk
when you don't have a place to talk
you're being excommunated from the
social media you cannot and the only way
that you're going to be able to say your
piece whenever people attacked you and
be able to defend yourself just merely
defending yourself
if I take all your social medias right
and and I cannot defend myself on things
that I've put out there
and people are just judging and often
saying and amplifying what I've said I
can't even go after that I can't even I
can't even defend myself so that's the
punishment hold on I don't understand
these people no you had people
celebrating when he got banned what do
you think they were celebrated him being
punished that's a punishment if you
don't why do you think he's saying yo
this has cost me money this is
definitely hampered me and I'm
recognizing the way with my messages
it's because he's been punished whether
you think it's fair not as irrelevant
she's debating whether or not he's been
punished this is the goofy talk you want
to say cancellation is not real because
people still have ways to make one the
way that people use cancellation
nowadays is not to me like you're
deleted forever it's to say that you
suffer tremendous social and financial
harm as a result of some kind of online
campaign by people so you're just being
prepared you're being uncharitable and a
bit disingenuous when you say he's been
punished how how he's losing millions
and millions of dollars from not having
access to any of his social medias or
for him being technically Shadow banned
in a lot of these conversations if you
will notice a lot of major take Clips
don't surface nearly as much now as they
did before because these social media
companies are actively trying to
suppress anything with those state
titles so you being you being a bit of a
liar but let's care it's where companies
take a decision which in my view in this
case was perverse because they still
allow for example the Ayatollah of Iran
to have a Twitter account yes so there's
a there's no consistency here at all
well but however we love a bit of free
market I'm sure you do you're judging by
that suit which is lovely
oh okay okay okay okay okay so we're
gonna be Petty but you know social media
companies are private companies
but over your point about you know if if
men were that Alpha then they wouldn't
be that bothered by this doesn't really
help us when it comes to boys growing up
and that is one of my worries that for
teenage boys now they are so terrified
of the consequences of putting a foot
out of line it was hard enough being a
young teenager working out how things
are working out how to do dating and all
of that without the terror that if you
touch in the wrong place at the wrong
time you may find that your whole life
is destroyed too much
[Music]
I think everybody should be frightened
in
I think that everybody should be
frightened and that's the thing you like
that Terror because it puts you in a
position when you are the endicapping
you're the one on the top and now all
these people are handicapped you're
gonna abuse of your power you know how I
know because it's happening right now
yeah
yeah y'all permitting yourself to do
stuff and I have to
tell people
tell women to not do stuff that they
feel really really nearly to do they
really don't care I was on tour you take
pictures with people the ladies will put
your their hands on your bum
and be calling you all sorts of things
they will freely want to do that
on tour and off tour
men have a sense of fear now cool
where's your sense of fear now because
you do the same thing
man girl if you don't get the [ __ ] out
of here with that thing see us here
these hyper feminists they want you to
be afraid yeah they want you terrified
they want the power
this whole idea that you know these is
there space for men in our that isn't
there isn't there there is
it's uh beneath them but oh you say oh
you said one [ __ ] one day that was nice
you don't want allies you won't serve it
servitude you said that and that's
exactly what the light ship is yeah you
that's not what you want you don't want
an ally you want servitude you want man
to be in position with you but you want
them scared and you want them as
servants that's what you want yeah
I think that men should be frightened I
think you're stupid
but that's not what she's talking about
she starts talking about men are afraid
it's like we don't know what's right or
what's wrong it's not always nearly
obvious and she's specifically talking
about young teenagers yeah they're more
specific the ones in development the
ones who have the least amount of social
interaction the least amount of
Engagement all they see online is how
terrifying the concert could be if they
do the wrong thing with links you know
and these young boys are sexless these
young teenagers these young folks in
general are getting intimacy a lot less
and you can say it's a good or a bad
thing but the whole point is they're
having less of this social engagement
with the opposite sex at young age how
do you think that carries over to the
older years in terms of development if
they they didn't have that [ __ ] early on
either so you've got to understand what
that fear does
I don't know why why should fear be the
thing governing
how our social interactions go because
you women are your women are afraid now
apparently to walk in the street I don't
I don't go around slapping other dudes
not because I'm I'm afraid I'll do it
because I think it's the wrong thing to
do right I've added a chance to learn I
don't want to be aggressive towards
people I'm cognizant of what it means
being motivated by fear just sounds like
if I had enough power and I was big
enough I would slap the [ __ ] out of you
because I'm not afraid of the constant
you don't want a world like that ideally
people are not engaging in certain
behaviors for reasons other than fear I
would hope but maybe you feel different
and the thing that happened is that you
are
in fear that's what you're you're saying
women say that often that they're in
fear outside
is that a good thing if you're confirmed
if by fear that's a good thing so you
know in your place you know when you to
talk you know what to do no it's not but
we're talking about yeah but we're not
talking about we're not talking about it
interesting thing that you see I would
say that that attitude actually is part
of the problem too that is that's to me
toxic femininity that is saying you
should all be terrified you men if you
put one assaulting well I I I think we
all understand what sexual assessor what
Isabelle's talking about is that young
teenage clumsiness in many cases which
is now being re-categorized as a sword
is that a problem not being
re-categorized as a soul it's always
been assault it's just we're finally
talking about I don't agree with that
it's ridiculous teenage boy fumbling
with teenage girls in most cases assault
do you remember Aziz Ansari right half
the heels of me too half the heels of
Harvey Weinstein rightly being dragged
through the courts and it should have
got way worse than just prison time in
my opinion azizan sorry had a consensual
relationship with a woman she felt a bit
awkward afterwards rescinded consent and
he was lumped in and he had his no I'm
with you on that one that's a great
example see she's saying it was always
well no we've literally stretched the
definition to mean a lot of things that
aren't I've literally heard someone get
yelled at and she said you're being
sexually I'm like what he didn't even
touch you How could somebody and people
were running with it and I was like
confused I'm like did we just change the
definition overnight yes we did we've
been stretching this [ __ ] for like
discomfort and saying I'm like what um
so you got to understand there's a lot
of confusion in regards to this stuff
especially for Young Folks even why
should men be afraid of that because he
didn't touch her without consent did he
nobody
supposed to navigate this I'm thinking
of my teenage son you know he's 14 15.
what's he supposed to say would you mind
if you are an extremely strong woman I
know in your house you're teaching them
the difference between assault and then
of course but what we're talking about
is it's been very interesting watching
the metoo movement and the time's up
movement how it's all developed because
a lot of very bad people Harvey
Weinstein and others got their due
comeuppance we can all agree with that
yeah this is not even something to be
debated we're really talking about the
Gray Line right where is that Gray Line
how do you navigate it when you're an
experienced adult and you've been around
the block in many ways you can navigate
that much more intelligently and with
emotional intelligence then you can if
you're a teenage boy and I think the
point Isabelle makes is a good one I've
got three sons in their twenties I've
always told them to be respectful to
women I believe they are but I do think
it's really hard for a 16 17 year old
boy now in this environment to know even
how to start having kind of some kind of
physical relationship with a woman those
good boys are all terrified I know that
from talking to my son he's just like
I'm just not going there is that healthy
yes I think it is actually I think it's
better to not have a physical
relationship than to have one that could
ruin a woman's life but then how do they
ever start well don't if you're not 100
sure we're gonna have a bunch of Newton
Boys we actually do have
don't so this is the kind of stupid
um
unrealistic sex ed talk that we've had
for a long time
don't want to get pregnant don't have
sex don't want to get pregnant uh
everyone just don't use a condom I mean
we think everything's solved guys
you have to understand how people
function there's how things should be
and there's how things are not how you
want them to be because I can want a lot
of things I could want everyone to
recycle tomorrow because it's really not
that difficult guess what [ __ ]
will not recycle
no matter how much you yell no matter
how much you put ads out they're not
going to recycle that's gonna happen so
we got to think about how Society
actually functions it's not enough to
say don't and if you don't know how
don't ever do it people still gonna [ __ ]
they still gonna get intimate they're
gonna drink they're gonna make mistakes
they're gonna get involved they're gonna
involved with the wrong people under the
wrong circumstances so what do we do in
those circumstances and her response is
don't you should be terrified
understand why these kind of people are
never going to offer real solutions for
our society because they're too busy
idealizing a world that doesn't exist
based off parameters that are not real
yes nobody should speak
people still do
nobody should break traffic rules people
still do either the negligence either to
inattention either to being compromised
so what do you do they tell you to be
vigilant on the road why
because even with all those measures in
place all these rules everybody knowing
them people still [ __ ] things up people
still are impulsive
you got to understand human nature and
what it is
so you're talking about hormonal
teenagers women flirting with them and
you think they're all going to have the
self-control to not engage in it until
they're ready that's not realistic this
is
I don't know maybe she's just never been
a teenager or maybe she's just like oh
[ __ ] I said adult [ __ ] are you have you
never been a teenager like who thinks
that deeply really
so I would just hope people rethink this
kind of rhetoric instead of thinking
about what should be how things are and
how we can improve them realistically
that gen Z is having far less sexual
relationships oh it's true and young
people have stopped having sex I agree
with the first part of your sentence
actually if you're not willing to have a
sexual relationship with clearly defined
lines don't have one and so I actually
told my my mates at University don't
sleep around with girls one girls don't
bring a guy home that you don't know is
capable of man look at this [ __ ]
square bruh yeah you're the conservative
talking points talking about well
according to the large lesson bruh
somebody here trying to get [ __ ] don't
be out here cause tell me not to get
away we're going to talk about some
[ __ ] not trying to get dick the
thing is not trying to get dick whoa I'm
talking about girls hey yo
and that's the thing we always talk
about this rhetoric where it's always
Man one and [ __ ] women want dick too
they actually do yeah they go in there
they want dick and they want to slap on
that knob they do all right we always
think that they never do in the
homination yeah they do they want they
want some dick them girl wants some dick
and that's the thing is that they want
some dick and at some point uh [ __ ]
maybe I shouldn't have the dick that I
had last night and he feels regret and
they might and it happened numerous
times that they claimed something before
something else yeah so let's not act
like it's just men out there want a dick
so let's not act like it's just man out
there wanna dig man out there wanna Dig
Two strikes [ __ ] no that's one last
Tuesday the first the first shot you
made it up
hey how did you decide is that one or
two strikes run it run it back bring it
back the first time they got yours
that's not we're always at this rhetoric
we're always it's always man wanting
[ __ ] and man going after [ __ ] I know
some very
girls are going after dick one girls
don't bring a guy at home that you don't
know what he's capable of two guys don't
bring a girl home if you think that
possibly she could have a false
accusation against you you can't it
doesn't work like let's shut up YouTube
boy you I was on your team but even you
it don't work like that that's like
here's this video saying don't marry a
girl if you think she's gonna divorce it
doesn't work like that when
[ __ ] are in the mood it they
have a different mindset of when they're
not in the mood stop
that's why you take your prenup before
you get divorce or before you get
married not when the [ __ ] goes down she
thinks that possibly she could have a
false accusation against you can I make
another Point here which I find I mean
look that sentence to me when I was your
age right how old are you uh 23 23. oh
okay
you got a 23 year old choir boy come on
bro when I was your age the idea you
would even have that sort of thought
process yeah I wouldn't have those sort
of mates that would ever cross the line
so I wouldn't have to no I never said
don't throw my mates in with a bunch of
violence she basically said like I
wouldn't hang around with dudes going
sexually who said they do that where's
this leap that this [ __ ] is making I
wouldn't hang around with people whoa
that's not even that's not even the
conversation so why am I so I wouldn't
even talk to you like you that's okay
crazy when you're arguing with people
at some point you have to understand
what their thought process is and what
they're trying to achieve and what is
what is it this right here I can't talk
to you I can't have a conversation with
you why because you're being dishonest
every turning point I'm saying you're
not even trying to understand because my
point whenever I go argue with someone
it's not that you're understanding
exactly what I say let's understand
where I'm coming from or you agree with
everything I say no I I it's not
possible to agree with everything I say
it's fine it's fine I want you to
understand my perspective but you right
now what she's doing
you're just throwing [ __ ] and throwing
[ __ ] you're just wild punching at
everything I say you're going left and
right and disrupting the conversation
and the axis of the conversation that's
what you're doing my girl so I can no
longer have a conversation with you is
there a certain Purity uh here of
detecting in a certain type of feminist
who thinks that they're all
unimpeachable and this is all one-way
traffic and the only men can be toxic no
because I gotta I've got to Enlighten
you I've met quite a few women in my
life who are pretty toxic themselves and
I don't see the debate being framed
around that at all can I ask you this if
you were going to go if you were going
to take someone to bed and you weren't
100 sure that they wanted to go to bed
with you would you go no I would not do
that but the point was Aziz Ansari was
sure for example and then later she went
and published a long piece right as she
regretted it and lumped him in with
Harvey once
you feel any of it Ava's gone too far do
you think the pendulum has gone too far
at all no no I don't think it's gone far
so he happens I'm sorry losing his whole
career pretty much he's dead in the
water you haven't heard much about him
since okay and she admits that that was
unfair then when he asked has any of
this gone too far since you know
girl if you don't just get the [ __ ] up
out of here with your [ __ ]
God damn something about feminist just
smells like period blood
damn [ __ ]
out of here
get the [ __ ] up in the core and get the
[ __ ] up out of here
what I don't know what the [ __ ] you just
said I said get the [ __ ] up in the core
and get the [ __ ] up out of here all
right cool okay or something about
period bloody [ __ ] I mean something
about feminism period Bloods and jars
yeah
and unshaven armpits you know what I'm
saying and profile pronouns you know it
comes with the starter pack we know what
it is no it doesn't come because it
doesn't get satisfied crayon
carry on carry on pretty much no no yeah
thank God that's the end because I can
watch more but yeah there's no having
there's no having a conversation with
this this it was not insightful at all
because well she's just stuck in a
little box and wants to talk about only
what she's talking about even if there's
a subject that is brought up to her she
just want to talk about her little
things and her little oh you don't know
that's my exception that exception and
that whatever I'm gonna say this though
say I've noticed a lot of women who are
fighting against this kind of rhetoric
more and more people will be like I
don't identify with this this [ __ ] don't
represent me this [ __ ] kind of crazy and
to you ladies out there who recognize
how crazy [ __ ] is and you guys voice it
we appreciate you okay don't notice
don't think I know don't notice you know
what I mean you wanted the good ones
come on in here all right anyways I know
it's good to do to know I do think this
kind of rhetoric is lame and as time
goes on we're going to constantly have
to fight back the needle on this because
we've seen enough people such as Johnny
Depp and others get falsely you know so
don't let people like this sway you just
know it's still out there it's still
prominent especially in these left-wing
bubbles but doesn't mean that everyone
subscribes to them right